so this is a what you're about to watch
is a song from a viewer about the
periodic table and I know you've seen
lots and lots of periodic table songs
but hopefully this one's a bit of a
difference Libby but Kenneth Nina mg
Alsip Espoir Kokoschka t4 Kerman feed
Kohaku's and gaggi a Sieber Karev Suri
sir demote a cruller PD AG could incense
be take sex policy per diem Sammy ug d
Timmy Howard me blue have Tory Ossipee
tau hg towlpb bit Petrin for a ex pas UN
pee poo and kombucha fess phone Midna RF
dbsg but her HUS Matt - RG Knut I think
that's very clever I think one of the
strangest things is that it makes the
periodic table seemed so short very much
shorter than you would when you go
through it all the time and Tom Lehrer
makes it seem to go on forever although
it's quite a short song ultimately
arsenic selenium hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen and rhenium but by just using
the symbols you'll most wish the song
went on a bit longer it'd be really
interesting to hear what the song let's
sounded like up to element 172 which
people have predicted but that would be
a bit boring at the moment because
they'd all be all whatever but it would
jazz up a bit I think when would they've
got some real name
holmium am haften urban phosphorus
transom fluorine terbium manganese
Mercury molybdenum magnesium dysprosium
and scandium a silly decision